المقاتلون الحوثيون المدعومين من إيران في اليمن يقومون
باستعراض للقوة بينما
يضربوننا والأعلام الإسرائيلية فقط في هذا التمرين،
يقول الحوثيون إنهم شنوا أيضًا
هجومًا واسع النطاق بعيد المدى على إسرائيل
باستخدام الصواريخ الباليستية وصواريخ كروز
بالإضافة إلى
طائرات بدون طيار للقوات المسلحة اليمنية.  نؤكد
أن هذه العملية هي الثالثة
لنصرة إخواننا المضطهدين في
فلسطين. يقول المتحدث إن
إسرائيل تؤكد الهجوم قائلة إن
قواتها الدفاعية تمكنت من إحباطه
باستخدام نظام دفاع جوي حديث
لكن الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل
اتهمتا منذ فترة طويلة إيران بتزويد الحوثيين بالمساعدات الجوية.
أسلحة بعيدة المدى، حصلنا على
فرصة نادرة لتصوير بعض ترسانة الطائرات بدون طيار
والصواريخ الإيرانية في معرض عسكري
في تكران في عام
2019 مع استمرار حرب حماس الإسرائيلية،
يقوم الإيرانيون الآن أيضًا باستعراض
عضلاتهم العسكرية في تمرين واسع النطاق مؤخرًا
يهدف إلى إظهار قدرة تون
قدرات دفاعية ولكن أحد
الجنرالات يوضح أيضًا أن
هدف الجمهورية الإسلامية هو تدمير
إسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالرسالة الموجهة إلى
النظام الصهيوني ويقول في الواقع نحن
نعلن تدمير هذا النظام
وسنشهده
قريبًا إن شاء الله، الجيش الإيراني ليس قريبًا
العديد من أسلحتها حديثة مثل الولايات المتحدة أو إسرائيل،
وهي مصنوعة من قبل
الثورة الإسلامية في عام
1979 مثل طائرات الهليكوبتر الهجومية من طراز الكوبرا التي تعود إلى حقبة حرب فيتنام،
لكن إيران تؤثر أو
تسيطر على عشرات الميليشيات في
جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط بأكمله والتي يقول تيران إنها
تستطيع تعبئتها لعدم استهدافها.  فقط مهاجمة إسرائيل
ولكن أصولنا في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة في مقابلة مع قناة الجزيرة
الرئيس الإيراني يهدد
بالتصعيد ما تشهده الأحداث في
غزة كلها خطوط حمراء يتم
انتهاكها من قبل الكيان الصهيوني يقول
قتل النساء والأطفال
قتل أكثر من  إن 3000 طفل
ليس شيئًا يمكن لأي إنسان أن
يقبله بشكل معقول أو ضمير، وتصر إسرائيل على أنها لا
تستهدف المدنيين في حملتها ضد
حماس في غزة، وقد أرسلت الولايات المتحدة
حاملات طائرات ومجموعات هجومية
وبطاريات صواريخ إضافية إلى
المنطقة.  الإدارة تحذر
إيران من التراجع بأننا سنأخذ أه
مصالح أمننا القومي على
محمل الجد وسنحمي قواتنا وندافع عنها وسنفعل
ذلك في الوقت والطريقة
التي
نختارها فريد لين سي إن إن
برلين